este terremoto se dio a la una y media
de la madrugada cuando la mayoría de la
población en afganistán se encontraba
dormida y si bien también afectó a
países vecinos como pakistán e irán en
la india el mayor énfasis fue
especialmente en esa región es cerca a
la frontera con pakistán en la provincia
de paktika donde habrían se habrían dado
el mayor número de fallecidos una de
esas poblaciones conocidas como gallán
sería la que más maldad que más sufrió
la mayoría de las casas allí habrían
quedado destruidas sin embargo esto no
es nuevo en aparezcan un país que lleva
muchísimas décadas sufriendo como
consecuencia de estos terremotos
solamente en la última década más de
7.000 personas
650 en promedio al año han muerto como
consecuencia de estos sismos y es que la
mayoría de estas poblaciones sus
viviendas son hechas con barro y con
ladrillo lo que hace que sean bastante
vulnerables y lo que ha llamado la
atención ya desde hace años de
organizaciones humanitarias y también
del pasado gobierno
es tan que buscaba reforzar y hacer más
sólidas estas viviendas pero la guerra y
la pobreza que vive el país ha hecho que
esta misión fuera imposible lo que se ha
hecho aún más difícil desde que los
talibanes tomaron el control del país el
año pasado en agosto del año pasado
cuando la pobreza se ha hecho aún mayor
el número de recursos que llegan al país
son mínimos y la ayuda humanitaria
también lo es esta escasez y esta
dificultad se ha visto reflejada hoy el
número de helicópteros a los que tiene
acceso a este gobierno son mínimos
áncash ha alcanzado a llegar hasta estas
poblaciones sin embargo esta ayuda no es
suficiente para evacuar al número de
heridos ni tampoco es esa esas misiones
humanitarias como consecuencia de las
dificultades geográficas del país por
eso se espera que el número de muertos
siga subiendo en las últimas las
próximas horas